es gibt jetzt ein neues corona heim und
zwar das pflegeheim bethlehem stift im
sächsischen zwönitz dort ist die zahl
der korona kranken noch einmal auf
insgesamt 84 gestiegen und ganz in der
nähe dieses neuen corona hotspots
befindet sich die klinik in aue marcel
koch ist dort geschäftsführer
er hat sich mit diesem hilferuf an die
menschen gewendet die zwei generationen
jetzt hier gerade akut gefährdet sind
das sind genau die die 50 50 jahre lang
im schacht den buckel krumm gemacht
haben
es ist nicht an euch zu entscheiden ob
diejenigen die augen zumachen das
entscheiden die patienten selbst und die
ärzte die sie behandeln
und wenn unsere erste die chance sehen
dass wir diesen patienten durch bekommen
dann werden wir das versuchen dieses
leben ist deswegen nicht weniger wert
das gleiche gilt für vorerkrankungen
stellt euch vor das ist ein autounfall
motors konnten und sieht niemanden drin
der zur risikogruppe gehört dass man
fliegen
das geht auch nicht stellt euch liegen
und vor allem wie sind die reaktionen
tja was hat mich bewegt irgend zu aller
erst waren die reaktionen auf den
kommentaren im internet natürlich sei
negativ mich hat gestört das relativiert
wird was ich gerade auch im video gesagt
habe dass ein leben weniger wird es nur
wenn man alt ist oder weil meine frau
erkrankung hat das ist nichts womit ich
mich in der definition kann und auch
keiner meiner mitarbeiter und deshalb
haben wir dazu auch eine ganz klare
meinung bezogen und die reaktionen auf
dieses video sind überwältigend
eigentlich machen wir diese videos ja
schon seit drei wochen dass wir immer
mehr aktuelle informationen rausgeben
mit einer lokalen verbreiterung und
inzwischen ist die verbreitung der doch
sehr sehr weit fortgeschritten
haben sie gerade angesprochen dass es
ihnen vor allem darum geht dass es ja
relativiert wird das ja nur in
anführungsstrichen ältere bisher zur
größten gruppe der todesopfer 10 jetzt
haben wir auch gerade erwähnt nicht
unweit von ihnen gibt es ein neues
pflegeheim in dem die zahl der fälle im
weiter ansteigt was geht in ihnen vor
wenn sie von diesem feuer hören die
jetzt überall aus sich ausbreiten in all
den pflegeheim seniorenheim hier in
deutschland im grunde genommen haben wir
das erwartet das hat auch die politik
erwartet deshalb haben wir ja seit zwei
wochen von den behörden auch verordnet
das herunterfahren der kliniken das
bereitstellen von zusätzlichen beatmungs
kapazitäten das bereitstellen von
zusätzlichen intensiv kapazitäten
ich habe einen freund in spanien er hat
mir das berichtet die haben einen etwa
zwei wochen vorlauf vor uns und er ist
dort geschäftsführer und er hat dieselbe
situation durch gemacht jetzt vor uns
liegt es sind immer die altenheimer weil
dort halt auch die patienten die am
meisten gefährdet werden also die
älteren mit vorerkrankungen natürlich
gehäuft auftreten
jetzt sprechen wir auch viel darüber
dass es nicht genug schutzmasken in
deutschland wie ist ihre klinik
ausgestattet was es was schutzmasken
angeht und auch beatmungsgeräte generell
ist es so dass alles was für die
behandlung und für den schutz gegen
kobelt 19 geeignet ist momentan
angespannte marktsituation aufweist
ich glaube es gibt keinen krankenhaus
was jetzt gerade aus dem vollen schöpfen
kann
unsere einkäufer sind rund um die uhr
beschäftigt material heran zu bekommen
aber grundsätzlich ist die lage in ganz
deutschland sehr angespannt